read in the script okay Hugh glass
fights the bear I'm like so how am I
gonna fight this mayor then you realize
oh yeah it's not a fight you're
basically like a cat with a ball of yarn
what's groundbreaking I think about that
sequence and why I think so many people
are talking about it is it's all it
almost becomes virtual reality in a lot
of ways it was Alejandro and chivo's
very specific work they watched over a
hundred different bear attacks because
you feel very voyeuristic like you're
watching something you shouldn't be
witnessing he almost awakens other
senses and I think people are talking
about it for a good reason that's a
testament to Alejandro and chivo's
masterful work they have a way of
submerging you into this reality and
making almost feel the tension the UN
the uncomfort a lot of what is so
powerful about that sequence is the
moments of Silence that they create the
silence between man and Beast and and
what's going to happen next and I think
that you know as a history of Cinema
unfolds people are going to be talking
about that sequence for for a long
period of time